[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat
c'était un des volets de la réforme pour
la modernisation de la justice depuis le
1er janvier dernier les couples peuvent
divorcer par consentement mutuel sans
passer devant un juge
les époux peuvent négocier les termes du
divorce accompagnés de leurs avocats et
une convention est enregistré chez le
notaire
cette nouvelle procédure doit permettre
de désengorger les tribunaux
c'est du moins la justification apportée
par le gouvernement mais que se
passe-t-il quand le sort des enfants
rentrent en jeu certaines voies existent
également une clarification des rôles
entre avocats et notaires avec nous pour
en débattre ce soir michel djian lascars
avocate au barreau de versailles
pascal louis guillaume secrétaire
national de l'union syndicale des
magistrats et anne marie picard mariscal
notaire associé à versailles bonsoir
mesdames
du côté des juges pascal ou emilio mais
on est globalement d'accord avec cette
réforme du moins sur le principe est ce
qu'on pense que ça va effectivement d
encombrer les tribunaux
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une majorité
de magistrats qui favorable à cette
réforme
avec quand même des bémols parce qu'on a
considéré quand même pour la plupart
d'entre nous que il aurait peut-être été
préférable de pas prévoir ce divorce
quand il ya des enfants mineurs là c'est
votre résidence que voilà c'est un
risque on verra comment ça va 100 ça
mettre en application mais nous en tout
cas l'union syndicale des magistrats
nous pensions que c'était effectivement
peut-être mieux de prévoir de limiter
quand y'a pas d'enfant mineur
michel djian lascars du côté des avocats
un nouveau rôle
vous êtes satisfait de cela et en même
temps vous me disiez en préparant les
missions que vous regrettiez un petit
peu la garantie du juge alors moi je
suis bien sûr favorable parce que ça
nous donne et c'est une confiance qui
nous est donné le pouvoir de négocier du
début à la fin
le cette convention contre signé par
deux avocats
c'est la mise en place de l'acte
d'avocat appliqué au droit de la famille
c'est très intéressant et puis ça va
nous donner la possibilité encore plus
d'écouté et de d'aller encore plus dans
l' écoute du client pour favoriser cette
convention mais je dois dire que par
certains moments il y avait ce contact
avec le juge qui parfois rappeler et au
parti justement quand il y avait
notamment des enfants en jeu leur rôle
de parents même dans le cadre de cette
audience il n'ya plus cela c'est à nous
de le faire et c'est parfois peut-être
un rôle qu'on n'avait pas avant qu'ils
nous attribuons va essayer de le mener à
bien et de faire comprendre les intérêts
tous les enjeux aussi concernant les
enfants
alors on reparlera tout de suite après
de cette réserve pour finir le tour de
table
du côté des notaires anne marie picard
mariscal c'est un nouveau rôle vous êtes
satisfait aussi
alors pour nous c'est un petit peu
différent je dirais d'abord le rôle du
notaire ne change pas fondamentalement
dans tous les actifs ou une liquidation
par acte authentique le notaire garde le
même rôle en ce qui concerne le dépôt au
rang des minutes de la convention
contresigné par avocat un débat cette
vert aujourd'hui encore beaucoup
d'interrogations
nous nous sentons quelquefois perturbé
par rapport à cet acte c'est à dire en
art urbain en quel sens écoutée l'acte
de dépôt chez un notaire c'est un acte
authentique c'est un acte qui donne la
force exécutoire est pour nous un acte
qui donne la force exécutoire nécessite
un contrôle approfondi par le notaire de
la capacité du consentement
or là il nous semble que cet acte est
différent c'est comme si on avait créé
un nouvel acte de dépôt puisque nous
connaissons deux actes de dépôt dans
notre profession
le des pauvres en dix minutes d'un
acte comme un brevet par exemple qui n'a
pas besoin d'autre chose que d'être
déposée et d'avoir une date certaine et
donc être conservés par le notaire et
puis l'acte de dépôt authentifiant qui
lui nécessite la mise en oeuvre de
toutes les missions du notaire et il
nous semble qu'elle nous échappe un peu
à travers cet acte effectivement très
bien donc il n'y a pas entre vous de
désaccords sur les rôles entre l'avocate
et le notaire finalement plus ou moins
quand même encore aujourd'hui il demeure
un doute puisque le texte si on se
réfère aux textes l'acte la convention
va être signée entre les avocats et leur
client
c'est un véritable acte d'avocat et on
peut le transmettre aux notaires or
aujourd'hui on n'est pas toujours
d'accord sur la façon dont soral se
faire puisque le notaire envisage de
dire que jusqu'au dépôt de son acte de
dépôt lui ne sais pas parce qu'elle
quand même un article de celle de ce
texte qui dit que juste même après avoir
signé cette convention une des parties
peule a dénoncé en faisant une requête
autres devant le tribunal et
effectivement les notaires disent oui
mais qu'est-ce qui m'assurent finalement
que les clients qui pour lesquelles vous
envoyer cet acte de dépôts non pas
derrière notre dos derrière votre
d'autres déposé une requête
moi je vois pas ce que notre déplacement
chez le notaire apportera de puces parce
que s'ils ont déposé une autre quête ils
vont pas nous dire et ils ne diront pas
plus aux notaires oui parce que les
notaires exige le déplacement de
l'avocat plus mais alors je pense qu'on
peut pas dire les notaires et gloucester
conjoint on est actuellement que je
voulais dit en réflexion entre les
chambres de nos terres les
arrow et pour essayer justement de ne
pas avoir de divergences sur l'acta
rétablir pour répondre à m durand lescar
le fait que cet article permettent
effectivement à des époux jusqu'au
dernier moment de changer quelle est la
meilleure assurance que d'avoir les gens
devant soi qui affirment qu'ils n'ont
pas changé d'avis les changes ou d un
côté solennel
bien sûr mais il s'est surtout qu'on a
en étant dans un face-à-face aucune
attestation ne pourra mettre à l'abri
d'un revirement de situation
est ce qu'un enfant après avoir dit
qu'il ne voulait pas être entendu par le
juge ne dira pas brutalement mais si
finalement je voudrais être entendue par
le juge
et à ce moment là comment aller mieux
chercher l'information que vis-à-vis des
parents en face à face avec nous voilà
c'est cela qui fait que
actuellement nous sommes encore à dire
que cet acte de dépôt doit être pour une
grande partie d'entre nous en tous les
cas en présence des deux époux et des
avocats mes avocats pascal viléo main un
point sur ce cette répartition des rôles
peut-être effectivement utile de
s'assurer que les époux sont toujours
d'accord même si je crois que le notaire
a pas vérifié le consentement des époux
au divorce
néanmoins étant donné leurs factures
d'interseroh de cassel voilà c'est vrai
que l'émission sera l'émission a trouvé
tout à fait les missions sont bien
répartis normalement il n'ya pas de ya
pas de difficultés après peut-être que
je peux comprendre tout à fait également
du point de vue du notaire il a aussi sa
responsabilité professionnelle
donc c'est tout à fait légitime qu'ils
veuillent également là serait alors on
envoyait des formalités qui peuvent être
faites par les époux jusqu'au dernier
moment et le rôle du notaire est formel
vous vérité c'est que la forme la
convention ivars clair en disant nous
devons vérifier qu'on a bien mentionné
le nom l'identité les références de des
avocats le fait s'il existe une
prestation compensatoire pas bien sûr
que ses formes elle bien sûr qu'il va
falloir tout simplement listé pour
vérifier que la convention d'avocats a
repris toutes ses dispositions
toutefois se limiter à ce rôle formel
nous laisse penser mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cet acte authentique où nous
n'avons aucun contrôle
dans ce cas à quoi servons-nous presque
oui mais bon là dessus à la clé un
avocat ont fait leur travail mais nous
on a fait de notre travail et on est
complètement dans l'application du texte
de moi il n'y a rien dans la loi qui dit
qu'on doit se déplacer chez le notaire
ou que le notaire doit vérifier le
bien-fondé ou l' équilibre de la
convention puisque c'est justement les
avocats qui sont en charge de respecter
ce que faisait m
avant le juge c'est à dire s'assurer de
leur consentement et s'assurer de l'
équilibre de la convention donc
normalement c'est notre travail je pense
qu'on l'aura bien pensé et qu'on aura un
vrai dans le sens du texte de loi et
dans le sens de l'intérêt de nos clients
et de l'intérêt des enfants donc alors
alors revenir dans le sens de nos
clients effectivement c'est peut-être là
aussi un peu ce que certains dénoncent
et que vos clients finalement décide in
fine et de ce qu'ils veulent inscrire
sur cette convention donc vous êtes
moins en tant qu'avocat en pouvoir de
trancher de dire non là je pense que
c'est pas équilibré je suis pas très
d'accord
d'abord on les deux oui c est d abord il
faut rappeler que pour appeler catcheuse
à vos clubs ont l'argent qu'elle est un
bon choix d'avoir un avenir pouvait
avoir qu'un avocat là nous sommes deux
et je pense que les avocats qui sont
investi de ce rôle vont quand même faire
le nécessaire pour s'assurer quand même
que les conventions qu'on dépose son
équilibré et équitable et équitable et
équitable bien sûr parce que voilà il ya
tout bien toujours services mais dans
n'importe quelle procédure qu'il y ait
un des époux qu'ils soient sous
influence de l'autre mais le fait
justement que le législateur ait choisi
qu'il y ait deux avocats
je pense que le but c'est justement de
rechercher cet équilibre dans la
convention et c'est un petit peu ce qui
existe déjà dans les actes d'avocats
c'est ce qu'ils
east aussi dans les médiations où nous
tentons par la vie de faire dire aux
gens ce qui eu les internats pas si les
clients viennent de dire de part et
d'autre nous sommes d'accord sur les
termes d'une convention et que nous en
tant qu'avocats nous estimons que cette
convention est équilibré c'est pas notre
rôle d'aller essayer de 2d de dire que
ça ne va pas et qu'il faut faire autre
chose mais c'était le rôle du juge
pascal oui les hommes de garantir un
petit peu ça est ce que vous ne craignez
pas justement certain manque d'équité
dans les nouvelles conventions
alors moi personnellement je le crains
pas partir du moment où maintenant c'est
trop c'est finalement cessé la mission
de l'avocat comme vous l'avez dit c'est
vraiment à l'avocat la fois de
conseiller son client
peut-être même au besoin de dire un
client maintenant écoutez là je jase
surplus voilà je vous représente plus
parce que là j'estime que je défends pas
vos intérêts l'avertir justement des
conséquences qu'il y aurait ainsi tous
les avocats vous faire cesser leur
déontologie avant le faire mais moi je
vous le ferai parce que si on me
présente une convention qui m'apparaît
totalement déséquilibrée jeunes moi je
dirais aux clients ben je suis désolé
mais si on poursuit dans ce sens là moi
je refuse je veux dire j'ai un rôle et
mon rôle c'est quand même de m'assurer
de but de l'équipe et pour moi n'y a pas
d'équilibré voilà est-ce que le notaire
peut s'apercevoir d'un vice de procédure
peut se percevoir d'un déséquilibre est
ce que vous pouvez réagir revenir vers
l'avocat ce que ça peut se produire en
garde d'abord je voudrais rebondir juste
un peu en disant qu'il faut quand même
pas oublier dans la plupart des niveaux
et par consentement mutuel nous
travaillons déjà ensemble avec les
avocats
donc c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau
et j'imagine absolument pas que les
avocats vont du jour au lendemain
changer et faire des conventions d
équilibre et je pense qu'ils
continueront à faire leur convention
comme il le fait actuellement
là où
je crois qu'il peut y avoir une gêne
pour le notaire c'est effectivement s'il
se trouve confronté à une convention ou
même s'il n'a pas à la regarder on va
dire
il jettera forcément un coup d'oeil et
il s'apercevra éventuellement d'un
élément d'extranéité par exemple et
qu'il aura un doute sur l'analyse de
régime matrimonial peut-être qui a été
fait ou bien encore qu'il perçoit qu à
travers la liquidation de biens même
purement mobilières il y a par exemple
des parts de sociétés dans des pays
comme l'espagne où on a souvent des
multipropriété par exemple eh bien il
s'apercevra que cette convention avec un
simple acte de dépôt ne pourra pas
s'appliquer peut-être à l'étranger donc
comment allez-vous vais revenir vers
l'avocat web
l'idée c'est de dire si nous pouvions
travailler en amont ensemble pour voir
déjà la convention uniquement pour se
dire c'est pas la peine d'attendre trop
tard pour voir ces éléments je pense que
ce serait une bonne chose et j'ai la
conviction que nous allons continuer
avec une majorité des avocats à
travailler dans ce sens on travaille
déjà sur tous les dossiers où il ya des
liquidations de régime matrimonial
on travaille en amont avec le notaire en
fait là il ya des divorces où il n'ya
pas de liquidation de deux communautés
où le effectivement le notaire recevra
notre convention terminée et que c'est
là on lui demande de faire cet acte de
dépôt sur la cad re alors vous êtes vous
êtes d'accord mais j'ai lu beaucoup de
voix là de désaccord entre avocats et
notaires dans la presse et autres mais
c'est vraiment en parler on aimerait ça
continue pour l'instant
pascal bouillaud mais revenons à cette
histoire d'enfant alors effectivement
votre réserve c'était de dire à partir
du moment où il ya un enfant mineur là
par contre on revient vers le jeu
alors nous nous verrons je pense que les
scènes que nous la situation aujourd'hui
un enfant a le droit de demander un
passage devant j'ai tout à fait de toute
façon c'est toujours un droit qui est
prévu dans le code civil depuis
plusieurs années il a eu un enfant qui a
effectivement qu'il ya une capacité de
discernement donc quand même pas un très
jeune enfant mais un enfant
effectivement en mesure de d'exprimer
une volonté certaine il peut demander à
être entendue et oscille dans le cadre
de ce divorce par avocat ils demandent à
être effectivement entendu las la
procédure ne peut plus continuer et il
faut continuer comme avant c'est à dire
je veux aller voir un juge alors
peut-être divorcer par consentement
mutuel ça sera toujours possible pour
les pour les époux mais en tout cas il
faudra qu effectivement le juge entend
de l'enfant et ils devront présenter
leur convention à ce moment là où juge
comme avant j'ai lu que certains parents
pourraient peut-être faire pression sur
leurs enfants pour éviter cette audition
voilà pour aller plus vite c'est une
crainte que vous avez l'une ou l'autre
ça que je pense que ça peut exister et
toute façon il y aura pas grand chose
pour pour contrer star voilà donc je
pense malheureusement qui aura toujours
ya quand même très souvent divorce par
consentement mutuel une pression on dit
consentement mutuel mais finalement il y
avait il ya des jeux psychologiques les
souffrances implique beaucoup de sons
avec un chantage
voilà tu auras la prestation à condition
de les enfants tu auras voilà beaucoup
de choses comme ça donc ça on pourra
jamais l'éviter c'est l'être humain est
malheureusement on n'aura jamais
l'assurance qu'il n'y a pas eu une
pression sur un enfant mais le juge
pouvait peut-être le sentir c'est là à
la différence non mais il le sentir si
je vous apporter parce que moi ça me
choque c'est la nec ce que nous devons
faire signer aux enfants alors allez
alors la vie morne radio a réussi trois
lignes alors il dit je suis né le je
suis informé que j'ai droit d'être
entendu par le juge ou par une personne
désignée par lui pour que mes sentiments
soient pris en compte pour
l'organisation mes relations avec mes
parents qui souhaitent divorcer
je suis informé que j'ai le droit d'être
assisté d'un avocat je suis informé que
je peux être entendu seul avec un avocat
ou une personne de mon choix qu'il sera
rendu compte de cette audition à mes
parents moi je suis un petit peu choqué
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on met
l'enfant à une place qui n'est pas la
sienne
c'est à dire que ça vous ressemble
l'enfant comme à comprendre
parce que c'est difficile et où des
bandages tout dépend l'âge mais on va
faire signer sa moelle autre jauge
annoncé sa une clientèle a éclaté en
sanglots
oui mais c'est pas possible tu peux pas
faire signer sa jeux d'écouté madame
cédant on en train de faire une requête
conjointe vous devez faire signer ça et
elle a eu et ça a été sa réaction
immédiate c'est de dire mais je mets mes
enfants je veux les protéger je n'ai pas
à les mettre et juste les termes de
cette lettre
on a l'impression que ça mais l'enfant
au coeur du conflit parental
alors est-ce qu'il est au coeur du
conflit parental à la maison et c'est un
progrès chacun essaie de le protéger
mais hélas inévitable
là il est d'accord lui demande de dire
qu' il a le droit de donner son
sentiment et c'est pour moi il est
les termes sont peut-être un petit peu
je sais pas moi j'ai trouvé un peu
maladroit pascal wuillaume sur cette
lettre alors ça c'est vrai que les
victimes en c'est une information qui
est donnée aux enfants puisque c'est le
moyen pour s'assurer que ils souhaitent
non être entendu bon je pense que ça
touche aussi la limite que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
nous les magistrats on pense
qu'effectivement c'est peut-être un
divorce qu'il fallait réserver au moins
dans un premier temps aux situations
dans lesquelles il y avait plus
d'enfants mineurs ou pas du tout
d'enfants mineurs
c'est vrai que c'est un problème parce
que c'est vrai que là on en place
effectivement quelque sorte l'enfant au
centre d'un conflit alors que la plupart
du temps quand même dans les taux de
divorce par consentement mutuel et
parents ont veillé justement à ce que
certes bah oui quitte il décide de se
quitter mais en général ils ont quand
même fait en sorte de rester des parents
vis-à-vis de leurs enfants est justement
de ne pas avoir des relations
conflictuelles avec les enfants donc
c'est un peu la limite le risque étant
on en parlait tout à l'heure d'un retour
de contentieux c'est à dire des années
plus tard ou je sais pas vous avez
peut-être eu des exemples comme ça
finalement des conventions mal ficelé ça
revient devant le juge
oui c'est un cardan cieux qui naissent
après alors finalement à vouloir
divorcer dans ces conditions on risque
de compliquer encore plus la situation
des jours avant dans ce tube est plus
important puisque c'est aujourd'hui on
est sur la base d'un résident d'un
divorce plus contractuels
est-ce qu'il va pas y avoir des divorces
sur le dol sur wii parce qu'aujourd'hui
sur la réalité la volonté des partis
c'est sur cette convention elle est
soumise au droit commun des contrats
donc on pourra avoir des vis du
consentement on pourra remettre en cause
cette convention avec et on vise va
lentement qu'on n'est pas les
conséquences sur les yeux ou enfin c'est
vrai que c'est très important donc on va
vite mais finalement pour une efficacité
en termes de pape à prouver mais on
verra l'avenir
voilà l'avenir le dira un point sur le
coût et le temps de cette nouvelle
procédure les français dans un sondage
il ya quelques années aux deux tiers
était favorable à cette procédure parce
que ça réduirait les coûts et le temps
qu'en pensez vous alors le temps
peut-être puisque on a plus d'audience
devant jules le coup pas sûr non jusqu'à
déjà deux avocats la place ce qu'on perd
quand pie xii
donc on double après ben il ya les coûts
d'enregistrement de passage chez le
notaire qui était pas qui n'existait pas
avant
50 euros inverse ils ont le alors pas
seulement c'est vrai il ya une subtilité
pas forcément 50 euros d'abord si le
travail est fait comme je viens de le
dire c'est à dire si on vérifie
certaines choses telles que la capacité
le consentement
ça demande un certain temps donc à
l'acte effectivement mais il ya aussi
tout l'accompagnement en dehors de cet
acte à nos yeux en tous les cas et qui
nécessitera une rémunération dont on
compte au total on va je pense en
sortirions arias je pense que ça sera
chargé à lui entre deux sens en allant s
250 wii 250 500 voire plus si vous avez
un élément d'extranéité à vérifier si
vous pouvez déposer cette convention en
tant que notaire
parce que on n'a pas que des franco
français à divorcer
bien sûr donc il faudra quand même
s'assurer que on n'est pas en train de
passer à côté d'un problème de droit
international qu'on s'assure de
l'application à l'extérieur de nos
frontières de cette convention et ça
c'est un travail supplémenté par les 40
donc je pense que ça variera en fonction
des cas je rejoins m en nascar en disant
que la plupart des divorces sans
patrimoine sans enfant ne poseront
certainement aucune difficulté
mais ce n'est pas la masse des divorces
par consentement mutuel bien sûr parce
qu'elle me guillaume est ce que au moins
sur l'argument du désencombrement des
tribunaux du recentrage du travail des
juges sur des vraies contentieux avec
des litiges etc ça marche cet argument
là alors je vais vous donner un exemple
je vais vous donner l'exemple du
tribunal de grande instance de paris
donc le plus grand de france il ya dix
neuf cabinets de jaf de juge aux
affaires familiales
l'impact qui a été évalué c'est à peine
un cabinet qui va se retrouver
effectivement déchargé de son activité
comment ça se passe et relaxation
compagne avait fait avancer ici enfin ça
a été évalué par rapport à l'or par
rapport aux nombres de consentement
mutuel
donc évidemment après avoir sucé sachant
qu'il ya soixante dix mille divorces par
an en france par consentement mutuel
pardon mutuel on est soixante dix mille
10 ans et je crois que ça représente en
volume global plus de la moitié des
divorces prononcés pour moi j'avais des
chips de l'aveyron j'avais au moins 200
et quelques milles divorce en france
dont plus de 55% à au titre du divorce
par consentement mutuel donc donc juste
pour terminer sur l'argument de
finalement redonner du temps au jeu ça
redonnera un petit peu de temps au juge
quand même eu très peu et un petit peu
également fonctionnaires de greffe
puisqu'ils sont chargés bien sûr de
toutes les convocations en amont et
ensuite des formalités donc une fois que
le jugement est prononcé ou homologué
mais quoi qu'il en soit ça va être un
impact assez limité pour pour les juge
pas pour la justice en terme de
de recentrage du jeu sur un périmètre
plus plus essentiel nous ce que nous
souhaiterions c'est qu'ils aient
d'autres pans effectivement de la
justice aussi bien civiles que pénales
pour laquelle on continue à avancer ou
en termes de réformes et de simplifier
maintenant un format de pain faut passer
à 120 sens voilà il ne faut pas que ça
se sait réforme se fasse au détriment de
l'intérêt ni des des parents ni surtout
des enfants
autrement c'est un risque pour nous de
voir un effet retour c'est à dire des
procédures revenir en contentieux
d'après divorce et où finalement on
n'aura rien réglé on aura encore des
contentieux on arrive vers la fin de
cette émission je voulais vous demander
sur un plan plus philosophique qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour chacune d'entre
vous de l'évolution de cette
procédure de divorce en 75 donc c'était
le consentement mutuel en 2004 plus
qu'un passage devant le juge aujourd'hui
plus juge
qu'est ce que ça veut dire sur
l'évolution de société qui commence
michel jonasz caresser peut-être plus
une banalisation de la fin d'une
institution qui le mariage et c'est un
constat si aujourd'hui on estime qu' on
a plus même le passage chez le juge qui
était quand même quelque chose de
solennel
aujourd'hui est ce que le fait de passer
devant deux avocats de signer ou d'aller
voir un auteur et de signer est ce que
ça a gardé l'importance pour les peaux
les gens qui divorcent ça on ne le sait
pas encore puisqu'on en est au début de
cette réforme
comment les gens ressentent le divorce
est ce qu'il dit ils se rendent compte
que c'est quelque chose quand même qui
impactent leur vie et celle de leurs
enfants
pascal viléo votre avis là-dessus alors
moi je pense que effectivement pas
seulement il ya des enfants mineurs
c'est peut-être effectivement retiré un
peu de solennité que de faire cette
réforme
après c'est vrai que mariage se déroule
sans juger donc pourquoi pas un divorce
amiable sans juge
c'est vrai que le mariage dans la sphère
privée alors on se dit que le divorce
peut l'être aussi
anne marie picard mariscal à et
moi je joue à travers ce genre de
réforme
la manifestation que les citoyens ont
envie d'une grande liberté sans vie de
s'approprier toute leur situation et
pour autant en contrepartie j'avais
l'exemple d'une personne qui devait
divorcer par consentement par convention
contresigné par avocat et qui m'a dit
tout simplement mais c'est pas possible
ça peut être aussi simple donc à la
limite
bientôt il pourra même pas venir et
voilà j'ai envoyé un email
ça allait être quelque chose d'assez
vite traité à distance et puis après on
va en précipiterait quelques rendez-vous
et puis voilà ce serait fini voilà j'ai
ressenti son malaise maintenant je pense
que
d'autre part il y en aura certains qui
vont être satisfaits de voir que ça va
aller plus vite qu'on n'aura pas des
dates d'audiences reportés à plusieurs
mois comme dans certains tribunaux et
qu'en conséquence ils vont s'en
satisfaire très certainement en termes
de science fiction judiciaire on peut
aller jusqu'à ce que vous décriviez est
ce qu'on peut ce sera de plus en plus
abstrait finalement est ce qu'on peut
imaginer jusqu'où ça peut aller même
très rapidement parce que les avocats et
les clients soient réunies dans un
bureau on peut pas faire par vidéo
conférence on peut pas on doit tous se
déplacer en un même lieu pour signer
donc on n'est pas encore dans mais ça me
pousse à devenir assez vu que le conseil
national des barreaux propose une
signature électronique des quatre mais
on a même rieuse et donc dans le dans le
même bureau on est d'accord par
électronique
oui mais alors naturellement choisi
raison est bon ils apposent leur
signature là je crois que ça change
merci mesdames pour votre participation
c'est la fin de ce débat je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine à très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]